11 heures arrivée à bezons roger delhi
les scènes de navarro qu'il va tourner
aujourd'hui c'est compliqué de se
glisser dans la peau du commissaire
c'est pas un problème parce que la
barousse et moi donc je ne sente pas du
personnage j'ai aucun problème de jeu je
crois aussi bien avec kaboul a toutefois
pas ils ont décidé d'eux de décrire le
personnage sur moi si j'avais été un
commissaire de police
c'est comme ça que j'aurais été tout le
monde est prêt sur le plateau y a pas à
dire ça use in 5 ont fait des longs
métrages indices d'un jour comme en
préparant bien on peut faire de très
bons films dont l approbation de
l'avenant temps assez court j'ai
finalement c'est bien aussi parce que
y'a une terrine table prescience
d'étonner guillon terrible et odieux de
se déchirer ou de sueur t on est tous
heureux ensemble sais pas si vous avez
vu sur le plateau mais il ya vraiment
faire très très très joyeux des décors
serbe tente ou défini commissariat de
l'appartement le lobby ya donc ça une
allure du sinn parce qu'on revienne tout
en tournée pendant deux ans et demi dans
le même lieu
si vous le rush plutôt qu aux yeux copé
en tout cas pas de doute roger grignote
non-stop et comme il paraît qu'il
voudrait faire régime
on a demandé aux comédiens des bons
conseils pour maigrir pour fond il faut
que tu fasses disent pas je t'invite
faut pas dormir les pieds écartés la
nuit entre le cassoulet et la choucroute
tu évites le big mac
du coup après tout c'est voyons bondues
je conseillerais tu connais un petit peu
puis de manger un petit peu moins gras
non il ne faut surtout pas changer vous
êtes très sexy et puis soudain roger a
disparu son siège et heavy notre équipe
a mené une enquête et l'a heureusement
retrouvé